welcome everybody hope you had a great
lunch
who is tricky to get people into
discussing do maintenance I know mark
sources our heavy lunch as opposed isn't
there's gonna be a very little code so
don't worry I want to start off saying I
have it and have an admission to make
this is not a new talk it's actually
three years old man I did it in this
very spot four years ago a Java zone in
a region so I dispersed I'm attempting
in English but I see this as a relapse
because it's not it's not exactly the
same talk I updated it of course because
a lot of things that happen since the
2016 especially in this crazy
microsoft's world so and i hear a lot of
people talking about mark surfs now and
also sang in the Singam maybe things
didn't pan out necessarily how we
expected it I'm not saying that I was
that I was clairvoyant
back then but I saw some issues that
could happen so it that does mean that
means it's quite interesting to go back
to the slides and see are they still
relevant and they are surprisingly never
still irrelevant and the thing is that
market serves ask me now kind of lock
this form definition I find that a bit
varying I mean people talk about like
neumann hair has talked about business
domains somebody talks about loose and
you did a hum talked about business
capabilities and I think cockroach
mentions bone in context and that comes
that's the central part of the main
Devon science so I wonder how much
understanding of how people having of
this because all these concepts are
quite vague right and we can easily then
end up saying my code number of lines so
the one I'm going to dig into that
domain during design part of this done
and I'm not the only one who says the
domain driven design is necessary this
is an acute from the MOOC on in London
recently I love that slide I suspect he
put it in because he liked the image
button and I've also heard somebody told
me that some human did something similar
earlier yesterday zoning I talked about
that you need to mind even sign to get
this going so let's see what this can
produce cannabis and once seen this I
believe I saw this first time we are but
2016 i tre at 2016 man idea to talk this
is a common thing a loss mark says this
makes us that the microsomes everywhere
and people got really fed up
especially those architects at our level
like the ivory top paratext they love to
send those males around with us but
Marcus Lee said our problem here to stay
it seems like it wasn't a hype anak has
become sort of the the default way of
doing modernization so I'm gonna say
firstly that this is definitely not a
peak and maxes at all I love services
they have to me that like sliced bread
I've really liked them all all life
services but I've been in service
orientation for many years so mock
service for me it's not really something
you at least that's how I interpret it
so that could me be my bias into it
there's somebody c-max herbs or
something pretty different than I do but
I try to build on existing definitions
that came way before mark services and
the cool thing about the same access is
that it seems like it is of more grass
root movement
it comes from the teams and the
developers like as I remember so ah that
was heavily event not driven like the
old Big East peace for those of you
remember those and it doesn't seem to
have gotten there yet with my service it
might so let's be careful
so anyone seen this slide before it's
just a few months I picked up this the
so-called Death Star Marxist Death Star
this is some we could end up there if
you're not careful and all saying that
this is the birthing sorry uber I think
I'm not saying that they have problems
with their mark services but when you
have thousands got to be tricky and hard
and I noticed somebody in the on Twitter
notice this I'm gonna masoom in be that
service not the rest so let's see if we
can get there but little and no any
interactions with others and my strong
belief is that you
have before you start on this journey
because this is a journey to go from
safe so I got a monolith and you want to
move into March services it is a journey
and you never start a journey without
some sort of a guide like a map or not
so much this earlier a plan because
pants are tricky don't use those
necessarily but you have to have an idea
where you're going and what you're doing
and it seems like maybe people are not
it's more seemed like more like a mob
culture of like just people hacking away
so how a strategy so let's try to see
what March services are I see them as a
spectrum they are at the end of the
spectrum that starts with a monolith at
one end big chunk big huge thing and you
got marks lives on the other end and for
me that's a forced economy I don't think
it is like a white it's not either/or
there are lots of of the nuances in
between here and I've been familiar at
least with a lot let's do the sorry
let's do the characteristic first large
as I said it's often have high coupling
a lot of stuff in the same place they
all couple together and there's local
yishun meaning that there's a lot of
stuff together that doesn't necessarily
logically live together they just are
put together by accident up just by the
sign because we want the big monolith on
the other hand we want something small
micro you want low coupling between
these things ideally and high creation
each component should be drilled to do
one thing and one thing well but in
between these two extremes you got the
model monoliths that some like Simon
Brown talks about about why can't you
start without well-defined modulized
monolith instead of running all the way
to microservices could he be a stepping
stone list or maybe you could be happy
with them armada monolith maybe that'll
help you or you could do something like
so what 2.0 I'm not sure that term is
established there was something Gartner
attempted to call it it's like after the
so our classical ESB so uh somebody try
to say like okay we want components that
send events between them let's call that
something else MA so uh chicken zero so
this is for those of you are familiar
you did on and probably man of yours is
dessert night conference
and suppose this event-driven thing so
yeah all right
but motorisation let's get back to the
I'm an old fart at least become one now
so let's go back and see have we done
this before and I'm gonna recognize this
code it's not cold so yeah I can't help
you a little
by adding that any clues anyone I would
be surprised if anybody did but this is
from David Palace from now in 1972 if
you replace modularization there with
Microsoft's of sub for example doesn't
that sound very familiar is that what
we're doing and in this paper which is
actually this this is a front page of it
I highlighted that line there it says
that the effectiveness of motorisation
normalization is dependent upon the
criteria used to divide in the system
into models so it's not just having the
models that's the thing is how you
create them how are they part of the
they are established and I see a
newspaper in this is a paper it's very
quite quite technical but it's readable
but he says there that instead of doing
a functional data Bishop decomposition
there we have a workflow you said that's
the surface and that's a surgeon that's
a service you must do it differently and
he's in suggests information hiding as
the concept Hughes said that if you can
find out what changes in a component
together and what what Shane can change
without having affect any others that's
how you sort of split it up but it's
completely different from what people
used to do back then yeah so why are we
one why do you want to do this much
social thing it to begin with no
modulation the old the old type and I
see it when I did is talk in Torrance
he's seen it was more about the
development speed and I've felt enough
didn't go well with agile itself Eliza
feature Factory kind of thinking gets to
get code out quickly and it is kind of
yes but it's more about reducing
dependence between components and teams
that's the important part you want to
reduce the coordination between those
teams that make those services I
shouldn't share services for something
and you can say that it could this be
actually a prerequisite for agile I must
admit I'm quite fond of agile and do a
lot of work on Nigel actually on these
days trying to not getting into there's
coaching bit but similar and I think
having Microsoft's is one of those
important architectural things that you
need to get in place to get proper gel
teams as Alan who love said you can't be
agile if you're finding your
architecture and I agree with that but
also in in in addition list there are
also other good things but Microsoft's
you can innovate easily just create
service outside but there are the rest
and just in a way that need tracer stuff
and you reduce the cognitive load that
is easy for you to get going with one
service without to understand the whole
big monolith like it at before
and this is it on board for people and
unfortunately also easier to outsource
some my like that some a.m. someone on
don't and of course also be the
technical part part scalability or not
but I want to start off with saying what
Marcos is not and I Nick this from
Mattias for us this is a brilliant
demonstration I said this is the
registration of the diagram of two micro
services and their shared database this
bodies is and I see a lot of this you we
create sirs and we did that back in SOR
one days as well creating a lot of
steroids or services on top of something
that is shared
she chunky big database usually so it's
not that right those are at best
functions they probably just crud
services they are there and they are no
I don't define those that might
resources and another one which is more
contentious probably is that it's not
entities it could go in this direction
abut you end up quickly understand
saying that oh everything is tied
together than if you do that it's
actually been established as an
anti-pattern basically do now I've done
it so it's a deep learning for me and
this is from telecom domain bar away and
we saw that you saw subscription
everywhere
okay let's define subscription seems
important Stabler something that the
domain cares about let's define that and
it was it was used everywhere and copied
card objects yeah and this is also quite
familiar for people in the audience this
is from 2008 bill Poole has a brilliant
set of blog post from 2008 recommend to
read that if you into so ah I want to
learn more about that episode this is
the sword ENT thesis you have a layered
architecture with the services there are
depend on each other I with another mark
mark shows I write I think hopefully
hope we don't get into that situation
again that we learned something from the
history and blog posts like this but
just need look quite similar this this
is from ubirr again I think how can I do
better I sit like that it's not there's
a lot of dependencies there right that
read service it's a lot of depends to be
able to deliver it it deserves it's not
independence not definite autonomous so
and I've seen presentation from Netflix
they have or actually Siemens find it
quite interesting that's Netflix is
always often used as a as an example of
how to do micro services I'm not sure if
you want to Netflix is Netflix they are
special you're probably not Netflix so
I'm afraid we go now I don't think
you're gonna end up here but we might
you're gonna get some time reading that
that's a good you how we saw so our back
in the days
way back to the big huge ESB that
everybody talked about and everybody
needed and I was somebody was calling
with some important people on yeah
people is a humongous piece I'm not
saying that we are moving in that
direction and now hopefully not because
as I said it's more of a grassroots
movement but we still talk I've seen API
gateways again a lot of logic in it
they're very central they get the
bottleneck for four teams and you got
even people are talking about
Microsoft's esps I mean I get shivers
but thank God that they're so and or sub
there are some good sites as well you
got lock on man you gotta give me a dis
is good for this but and they are more
of a technical level so I don't see that
those are certainly SP necessarily but
but service measures should become one
so let's get back to this because hmm as
I said much service is not necessarily
well-defined so some people see
Microsoft's as I just lack of better
just use the mujer for that that's the
James Lewis thinking couple episodes so
they are not very small but they're at
least somewhat sizable and you've got
this none our services I would call them
and also like like the old there's us so
what Pat a book they also refers to
these as non services they are too small
they really invent to each other and
then you can risk of getting to this
situation which for me looks like a lot
of people has gotten themselves into
you got the whole model is still
everything is the same thing there's a
little did they enlarge this large
system
highly coupled this localization as one
component can be of course behave lobe
creation but the whole system has a high
cohesion that's the low question sorry
and sort of create them on it and just
add it in network in between and you got
all these lovely fallacies of this
Buddhist computing so this is also a
slide that I had back in 2016 and I was
I wasn't alone be worried
this is Kelly summers she saw a business
opportunity here I'm not sure if you any
of you have been in as witches and
harden and said we need help much is
everywhere but all the people saw it is
like Steve Jones you need enhance or
this
a lot of people I wasn't alone so let me
do a little bit of a dive into what
services really are micronauts and for
me it the central thing is actually
doing service orientation that's what
you doing
and seen again this is a dotnet you
probably know don't box BCF guru he
created something called tenet of
socialization they're not bad I stood
there okay there are bit dated but then
down of that boundary so explicit he
says they should be and kind of make
sense from those days where you had core
bar and distributed objects and you
never knew if you your call was going to
them to the process within your server
or some other side of the world you
didn't know so this is making that jump
explicit autonomy again and he also
added a few others which are probably a
bit outdated now but still you shouldn't
share types which is ship schemas
schemas and then the contracts and
services copper bill choose good based
on policies I think these are still
surprisingly valid and puffin probably
loss to recover lease holders basically
but especially the second one I think we
fail a lot on that and remember this
this was back in 2004 Berlin and I saw
first I remembered so I back then it was
a lot of focus on reuse if you create a
service you should create it should be
reused if not it's not you don't get all
you want from them so they should be
they should be yeah they should be reuse
but it's nothing about reusing and I'd
really like this drawing for some reason
just to show you what the service what's
new with our service a lot of people
ended up stop seeing services just API
so interfaces but they are not there's
something more to them this is our
evolution from the Barbican and a.22
what services are you start the early
days when when you wrote functions well
imperative and then you moved into
components create a more coarse-grained
and then serve something really
different they are they contain
the other stuff but they also contain
data which is really important and in
this toward the end I insisted that they
should use events for interfaces so they
are they're not they assess you did a
homicide
they don't serve they just are sounds
fluffy but it kind of makes sense so
okay this is revelation modularization
what can this do for us
Kandinsky bye ladies commander ensign
kind of kicked off the whole thing was
this Bluebird still surprising the
relevant book I still go back to time
and time and again and find news
knowledge in it that I missed the first
time I read it I remember as me probably
as many of the other ones to try to read
it you don't read the full book first on
you stop about halfway through you until
I get you to the fluffy stuff and then
you start coding and then you're on
written or written your hope is based on
those practical patterns and ignore all
the and sensory stuff that's later on
but for me after doing the reminder
enzyme for about 15 years now it's it's
not really about the patterns like they
call it patterns but patterns is a bit
tricky word because you see pattern you
just go and copy and follow the recipe
and you're done but it's more of a set
of heuristic for me the sort of
principles that guiding guidelines
there's this more of a which makes it a
bit more fluffy but yeah it's it's way
more than those patterns if you like
it's a way of learning there's a reason
why school domain during the summer way
yeah you domain should drive here you
should it should reflect the business
that's the thing so this is this is this
is summary of the main difference and
I'm sure worst where this is from I
think it was the 20 when some reference
free book tour doesn't invoke you so
this is a three point summary of essence
of the winter and sign so it's the color
with a collaboration between the
software software the engineers or
certain developers and business or the
domain experts so this is this is also
back to what some of the so I expect
ready to communicate is the IT
IT business alignment this is all a line
without there's a shared understanding
between these parties and also you
should you shouldn't necessarily do this
all over the place my first attempt we
did that everywhere the main team ensign
tried to get patterns everywhere
not necessarily worth the effort should
focus on the core demand where it really
matters and quarter manual I mean what
part of the business are what part of
your companies did really central to to
today and their workings what is it that
I make them different from others what's
the competitive advantage so to speak
and also this tricky term ubiquitous
language which generally mean that when
these people work together they should
create their if they should together be
define language so that they speak the
same language but the language shouldn't
be generic shouldn't be everywhere it
should be within the bound of context
and we're gonna get into that what does
one context is but just yeah for now
let's leave it at that so let's open up
the toolbox this is the whole list and
of course I'm gonna use the rest of the
talk to go to every one of them in
detail because that you you does what
you do gonna have a patter but right you
implement everything you more you have
you better this no that's not how this
works
you take learning from all of them keep
them in mind and imply and employ the
ones that you find useful in your
situation and I really love this Lachie
deep part which is these and the bigger
they are the more important they are can
you come us so here you have the bound
of context again you have a core demand
which I mentioned earlier on there and
you pick this language right these are
the central parts to the manual design
so that's how you would you use this and
I'm Nick this one from Nicky tuna blade
from his book yeah so you have associate
you have this you have you have a
problem the main and the business want
to do some changes to it so the domain
expert and develop between sit together
and sort of figure this out what do we
have
what we wanted and doing that they
create this jubatus language together
what does that mean it that doesn't mean
that he that the business has the roller
rights to define those terms it should
be defined together was developers have
a lot of good input when it comes to
terms maybe even this is the matter of
expert actually so developer that's been
around been around for ages so it's a
collaboration and with that language
they start to dig into the domain of
course they do listen in a trivet way of
course and with this to my knowledge is
described in that language and then then
you stopped modeling first you say okay
let's find out what sort of are these
domains that we talked about earlier and
what is the core demand what is this
supporting domain or its enactment and
these these type of terms are just
saying how important are these domains
to the business so as I said earlier
folks on a core domain and then you stop
modeling and sort create ideas how you
can solve this for every every domain
and here we are into this permanent
context those models we need associate
minds they are within that bounded
context they should be that model is
only only valid in within that context
for that sort of man and a way of
finding these domains some people of you
some of you might may know that I have
some talks on what about what is called
business capabilities this is one way to
find those domains without like well I'm
necessarily having that discussion as I
said with drilling on language but you
can just look at the basis what do the
business do what are their this is a top
level map where we have the enterprise
it has some management stuff corporate
management has an oversight but then it
does product development it does
delivery it was supportive services and
market development those could be
domains right at least somewhere to
start and you can break this down
further I can say the market development
that is also constructed by different
capabilities and you can break this down
further on
three or four levels is Manama so it
depends on where you are your domain is
where you where you're at where where do
you work what sort of support business
support are you providing so let's look
into these subdomains and what and how
you can use language to find those
barriers and what that could look like
so I'm just making those here from the
capabilities you see how you have some
something about subscription management
something we have some billing and we
have some custom okay so within
sufficient management you probably have
an owner of a subscription this is from
telecom domain barway so I have a
subscription which has an owner but that
owner in the billing of the mind it
wouldn't be an owner anymore
surely it would be a payer so it's the
same same entity same thing but
different names in customer care it
could actually be just be the customer
but I actually had a long discussion of
the thumper company where and we
couldn't find a customer anywhere like
explicit they ain't only way I only one
place we found was in bi that's what I
was really interested in customers
customer care usually just interested in
since this is in tickets and stuff like
that and I am on example portfolio there
was a portfolio of subscriptions in
bailing that could be your billing
account as how you build that's the
level you belong and customer care could
be your install base that's the products
that is good the the cost math and one
other ones Egyptian and billing that
could be sales invoice and in customer
care I could be products you see
different names for different contexts
or different domains so this is one way
this is already a classical domain
driven design way to find it ideas
domain see where does the terms change
names where did I behave differently
but Ana and these models and we all as
you all know this is probably that all
models there there's no one perfect
model malls are not perfect they are by
the sign wrong because that's why we do
modeling if not we wouldn't do it we
just do the real thing and within each
of these domains you would create a
model that's perfect or as a fit for
that and good enough it for that domain
that doesn't mean there was a model
across all these domains that wouldn't
that's not what I meant even Sciences so
again we need that bound context this
one annexed from one Baroness book and
completely Spokane yesterday and here
you have a list of debates again I just
used use these types the core domain
sporting and generic how would how about
the bound context filter ideally you
want found the context be one-to-one
with that we did domain very often a
more often or not they're not if you
come from only for example then you ever
have a bound in the context that crosses
many domains maybe even wall if you're a
really big one and here a nice example
to see how he s taking care to create
that context within the core and the
supporting domains you see effort a I
can also mention that when microservices
broke a lot of the dddd people was a
funny saying at last we have some
enforcement before to enforcing those
boundaries the banner context I really
haven't said that at last some
boundaries physical boundaries
alright let's go back to this how would
you do this in our domain during the
sign come off thinking that maybe
something like this don't look at the
names because this is just an
illustration so they are probably not
gonna fit but yeah you could so Marcus
if these where microservices didn't
domain imbalance to be just a grouping
of services as Evan said it's a cluster
of co.design services so how you break
up that domain into components we can
break it up as much as we want but they
are built together they are
maintained together within that context
what about the mine and a good thing is
when they'll sort of the cool thing is
then when we do when you do this is that
you can you can have different rules
from within the domain and I'll cross
across them north/south I mean between
the top layer and bottom you can do
synchronous course not from command same
whatever you do wanna do cross them
you wanna beast have this loose coupling
autonomy autonomy you can do events for
example what you want do are different
rules for different situations
east-west ability Cola and also
ilustrate where you can draw it and make
the drawing all the way to the top which
here is actually an application but it
could be you I had there's been a few
talks there about conversation or
microphone that's just an example of
that i--dude the service actually goes
all the way out to the UI compose and
another cool thing that just came to me
the other ways that events then it's
actually a good enabling constraint what
to say if you if you enforce the events
between them one thing is that you get
this loose coupling but also it changes
the way you think about the sign because
then you wouldn't be in you wouldn't
have you would have to remove that sort
of what is called behavior coupling that
you need something for somebody else you
can't do it anymore heroines because
then it's just communicating what what
has happened that's the definition of
element it's just a fact that you'd
share with others yes I'm gonna dig a
little bit into one pattern from the
tactical part three and that is the
aggregate which is quite interesting it
took me a long time to understand what
the aggregate was and probably hasn't
figured one percent out yet but I still
think contemplating it but for me it's
um we used it back then as a pattern as
we have actually class was called
aggregates Enola you know building I do
the truce and the whole thing but for me
now it's more of a way of thinking again
it is an aggregate example of it here
again from the telecom domain an
aggregate is a way of enforcing rules
business rules invariants and by doing
that that means that it's not a staff
thing it's you have one for every use
case it is like command handler if you
like right there's some there's some
interaction that comes in and the
aggregates protects those in invariance
and business rules and and and in that
picture they don't control them they
control the change they are not to
change themselves this change is
actually the event or the result of what
is happening within that I get but a
cool thing is a Goods one of the
definition is that they should have did
transactional boundary which means you
probably shouldn't make anything smaller
than an aggregate because then you got
cross transaction across components in
the Microsoft world so they should
that's probably the lower and that's why
I think that the tiny tiny tiny Fred
George type of non services are probably
not good choice at least everywhere an
example of how you can decide okay can
work I'm not saying this a good it is
good because I think it would probably
bitten it if I did it again now but you
have an aggregate and there's a
portfolio and you add a new subscription
and they see that this is the same
subscription that you have before it so
it can you add that then that's the rule
maybe maybe you couldn't count the
counter duplicates but no that's how I
would work so I think there is a there's
a taxonomy kind yeah at the big and we
don't have the monolith because way into
services here you have the big services
more this so up 2.0 type of services I
showed earlier which is actually the
whole domain abundant context could be
one service or it could be more of our
yeah a part of that service that is
self-contained I mean I think it is
stuff until cover has this this
definition called self-contained
services which are by definition smaller
than the bigger might they are part of a
say it's a web page that you cannot
create or something and on the other end
you happy I could get as I say that's a
small part for me it's it is a taxonomy
here that it is the surfaces should be
it would be as large as a served mine
and not smaller than and I
so I think it I'd sent the fall a little
bit in between here I think the the
subdomain will not be too large you want
to have more flexibility in your in your
architecture so how would you go about
splitting you normally we create when we
get a break I'm honest we that's the
selfishness first they should want by
the time that's normally what we do I've
done that I have a big monolith oh let's
take the hello hanging fruit let's take
the obvious stuff out first oh that was
easy
okay how do you go from here and it
seems like a lot of people just hack
away and I think we should have more of
a strategy here because we risk of
ending up in something like I'd like to
illustrate like this is the break get
completely into small pieces and it's it
doesn't it doesn't even look good it
doesn't make sense it's sharp it could
you can catch yourself and it's it's
terrible so I and I think as I said
earlier that when people start hacking
away it seems like alley there's a mob
mentality going on earth did you could
just go ahead and break stuff first I
walk and it's a slippery slope because
there when you start doing those small
beat pieces first seems easy and then
you get going and before you know it
there's a lot of teams done the same and
suddenly you have hundreds and thousands
of microservices and you interrupt I see
people now same companies doing this and
it's they come calling and I can you
help us with the mind when I sign with
her that could help us yeah and I think
I actually think for all the good things
that containers and services gives us it
is also a huge opportunity to end up in
some valleys people just hacking away
because it's easy I picture something
like this just to be following the
analogy an analogy of glass that you
should have as I said earlier I don't do
sell say that you should have a plan but
you have at least some strategy of how
it should break things apart have a map
of some kind have an idea how they
should look in the end
what sort of domains do you have however
what sort of services are you
auditioning having in the end when you'd
finished this
because what we're doing and essentially
doing it we are creating what some
people refer to as social technical
systems because we are not all these are
not until just technical stuff they are
involving people and teams and if
somebody creates don't service over here
and that doesn't that conflicts with
another one team gets into problems and
issues so I I suggest that you try to
find out what your end goal is how
should they look have a map and be
guided by domain driven design for
example or so or capabilities or
whatever you like but have some affront
and some wanna bring some attention to
this probably read this post by Martin
Fowler he said you have to be this tall
to start doing micro services and I've
laughed at it I'm sure a lot of you have
laughter the chief right why bother
but there is something to this and what
he says that you need those four icons
they are rapid provisioning basic
monitoring rapid application development
and Niko said okay that's your opinion
man like I don't care just hack away
that get going but we got some data on
this now it's the obligatory accelerates
reference that book is absolutely a gem
of a book he'll see a low performers I
had this number of developers said and
not known as a cell number of services
but I tackled a line and what the deploy
frequency is for low performers they
degrade when they scale medium flat but
you see the curve on the top so I think
there is something to what them
followers are there you should probably
have some ideas how to do the only stuff
before you get going with a miter saw
splitting you don't want to have end up
in a gray light gray line they're
degrading so
I want to actually been gone and early
on I was like but what we're doing is we
are creating complex systems and this is
a I love this quote from John Boyle a
complex system that works is invariably
found to evolve from something simple
and if you try to create a complex
system it gonna fail and have to go back
and start simply again so by doing by
sort of having I wishes yes that say if
you have a big moment and you break it
up break it up into big piece maybe even
start with a modular mineralization on
it don't break it out as much service at
all just start model icing and use big
components like for example those
domains and then start doing the
splitting for stuff that you see that is
really that you need say that's like
there's a sort of a to be reducer sort
of business teacher but there are
certain return of investment for doing
that service so did a so to summarize
start simple long stop for where you are
you can experiment but to have that
whole picture have them try to find
create that map as I mentioned earlier
just use business capabilities use
domains domain driven design find find
out what you domain so stop
understanding the business deeply
because that is what doing domain during
Sun gives us techniques for doing that
or huge sticks and if you don't have
that I would suggest that you start with
that monolith or module one preferably I
remember mark chefs are not for all
because it's and everybody does it
doesn't mean that you should you like
the system and your big moment might
just be just fine for my aura do you
have any data saying that new monolith
is actually stopping you or preventing
you it has served you well probably or a
staff until yourself said love that word
successful system sucks right so don't
throw that legacy data legacy system
outward with
and I was thinking throwing the baby
after that we will be the bathroom with
the bathwater so take care right
that was my - thank you very much for
your attention if you have any questions
that can be found on Twitter and also a
small shout out to the main TV sign
Norway where you can meet me frequently
there's a meet-up come on Jonas thank
you